[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as well and it's going to be
a great day beginning with a mother who
wanted to help her daughter and other
college students find peace and she came
up with a clever and very cute way to do
it also a college athlete making history
in the game of baseball pretty sweet
swing there and a baby who survived the
devastating earthquakes in Turkey was
left without a mother or so they thought
stick around for answers plus
researchers who have some interesting
Neighbors in Antarctica you're going to
get a close-up look at the emperor
penguins they're studying
plus a little girl with cerebral palsy
who found a role model just like her CBS
News was there when they met for the
very first time we got all that plus
your heartwarming videos the ones you
just need to see you know what you're
watching The Uplift
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decopo this is the
uplift it's a show that lifts you up for
at least the next 30 minutes I would say
you and me as well and we are going to
begin here with a mom in Wisconsin who
saw her college-age daughter stressed
during the pandemic and she wanted to do
something to help her and also other
students in town Caitlin O'Kane has a
story
a Cozy Cafe in Whitewater Michigan is
serving up more than just coffee they
provide cuddles and cuteness too with
cats Natalie Cerna a former nurse and
single mom was inspired to open Barista
cat's Cafe to help the college kids at
nearby University of Wisconsin my
daughter goes and she was a big big part
of my inspiration during covid she was
locked in her dorms freshman year why I
chose White Water
because it was so hard for her and to
see these kids struggle for their Mental
Health
I don't want to see the kids have to go
through that Natalie says cats have a
healing benefit and she wanted to bring
that to college kids and senior citizens
in Whitewater it really reduces stress
it reduces anxiety and it that not only
for the humans but for the cats she got
help from Wisconsin Women's Business
initiative corporation which helps small
business owners reach their dreams and
now she's helping customers and local
cats the Humane Society provides all the
cats for the cafe meaning they're all up
for adoption so these cats often go into
the shelter and they are shut down
they're scared they're depressed but
when they come here they come out of
their cages and their personalities
really shine in just over a year more
than 30 cats have been adopted by
customers who get to bring those feline
healing powers home with them from
Barista Cats Cafe
the beautiful piece from one beautiful
story to another we're going to
introduce you now to a young woman
making college baseball history here's
Meg Oliver
Watch Out Boys of Summer
[Music]
town and she means business this was my
goal throughout High School to play
collegiate baseball regardless of the
division
nineteen-year-old Olivia pachardo made
history recently as the first woman to
make a Collegiate division one baseball
team an outfielder for Brown University
in the ivy league I knew that I wanted
to play college baseball but I also
wanted to go somewhere that had
academics that fit the grades that I had
in high school picciardo chose brown
with a plan for a walk-on tryout she
approached things with calm Grand
Achilles is the team's head coach how
many women have reached out to you to
try and try out for your program there
have been a handful a handful since live
certainly none before she was the first
yes she was the first how would you
describe her as a baseball player so
she's very meticulous with her
preparation and she's a contact hitter
that wants to put the ball on the ground
and play solid defense in the Outfield
the dusty baseball diamonds of Queens
New York have been a part of pachardo's
life as long as she can remember who
taught you how to play baseball uh my
dad I kind of inherited his love for the
game and he knew that he wanted his kids
to play baseball so it all started here
in Queens all right here and this is the
path that we took to the Little League
field Olivia's dad Max grew up playing
baseball in the Dominican Republic and
was eager to share the sport with his
kids he got Olivia on the diamond when
she was only four he still has her first
fat pink and yellow it looks so small
now but uh on the field way back there
when she said when you play when you're
the littlest she would come out to the
plate and she would slam that crap out
of the bat on the home plate Olivia
became a pitcher an outfielder and was
able to hold her own with older boys as
a seventh grader she made the high
school boys varsity team that was always
the thing that I look forward to oh
practice at the end of the day today a
game at the end of the day I'm gonna
pitch today I'm so excited
well many girls take to softball it was
never a consideration for picardo she
graduated high school with a sizzling
fastball
and a sparkling GPA
and while pachado has always been a
standout she's also always found a way
to fit in just ask her Brown teammates
the first thing I was impressed by was
just how she threw the ball it's a good
sign of just what a baseball player will
be I was also impressed I hadn't really
played with any girls since little
league and I was pretty excited to see
what what she could do out here as a as
a Fishman Walk On Olivia wasn't
guaranteed any playing time but on March
17th with proud papa filming from the
stands
pachado became the first woman ever to
bat in a division one game it was a
ground out but it was history
what do you want other little girls out
there to know that are playing baseball
right now I guess I would tell the they
should be playing this word that they
love for as long as they want to play
if you can play let them play that's a
great swing she's got there coming up
after the earthquake in Turkey a baby
survived the for days underneath the
rubble days her rescue nothing short of
a miracle but it's what happened next
that maybe even more miraculous stick
around you're watching The Uplift
foreign
videos ones you just need to see this
one comes from Georgia where an elderly
dog named Binky disappeared three years
ago the 18 year old pup ended up six
hours away from home and in a completely
different state in fact Dorchester Paws
that's a shelter in Somerville South
Carolina used his microchip to identify
his owner and a volunteer then drove
Binky all the way back home what you're
seeing on your screen now is the
emotional moment when his mom got him
back after three years
hi oh goodness
oh
you're home bud
no that is a really sweet one there love
that all right recent earthquakes in
Turkey they left a devastating trail of
Destruction killed more than 50
000 people ponder that for a moment and
in that Darkness
we do say there was a symbol of light
after surviving
128 Hours in the rubble a little baby
was saved here's Natasha lorno with this
story of survival
when an earthquake ravaged turkey this
baby girl was buried underneath the
rubble for 128 Hours and yet she
survived
she was about a month and a half old at
the time and she was put into State care
it was believed that her mother died but
about two months later a family member
reached out to officials claiming the
mom was still alive and that she was
being treated at another hospital so she
took a DNA test and it was a match and
after 54 days apart and countless
volunteers and strangers helping the
baby was reunited with her mom
[Music]
they're the only survivors from their
family but now the miracle baby is
finally back in her mom's arms the
mother a survivor the baby a miracle
now back together
love there finds a way coming up a trip
to Antarctica to get a close-up look at
emperor penguins
plus meet a five-year-old girl who
connected with an important role model a
role model who lives all across the
country clear across it see the moment
they met for the very first time in
person
[Music]
it's been more than a year now since the
war in Ukraine started millions of
people have begun to flee their Homeland
the country of Ukraine and last year CBS
Minnesota's Aaron Hassan zadeh met a
family from Ukraine
just after they arrived in these United
States she recently found them again to
hear about the life they're building
here
literally I took the shirt off my back
some documents and ran away we first met
Alina Nutella and Valentina one year ago
when it was fresh someone to go home I
really want to go home their homes in
mariopol Ukraine destroyed so they ended
up here in Minnesota we escaped there in
great fear one year later my husband is
here he arrived my children arrived
thank God that we are all together now
most of their family is here settling
into their new lives with a new family
member Milo is the most important
development currently
Milo was a surprise gift for Alina's
daughter
who's thriving at school and in the
neighborhood
they're playing together across the
fence throw toys across the fence to
each other she even met another girl
from mariopal in her class Nutella who
was a dentist in Ukraine is taking
classes at an ESL School working on
English medical term analogy to
hopefully eventually work in that field
again and speaking of fields when it was
the summer
I was always gardening and doing a
little bit of farming I would grow
vegetables Tomatoes flowers cucumbers
Valentina is thriving wonderful medical
care I really love the nature here
excellent nature I love this winter so
so beautiful I am very satisfied I'm
very fulfilled I feel good because of
the timing of their arrival in the
states they didn't qualify for certain
programs their Parolees DHS tells us
their status in the U.S was just
extended one more year this conflict is
not going to stop in the near future
and because of the fact that even if it
does as we've heard from this family in
mariupal and by and large other parts of
Ukraine it's been leveled down to a
field attorney Nadia royfey gets calls
from families like this on a daily basis
they're looking for guidance to
eventually solidify a more permanent
status here in the U.S individuals as we
heard want to work they want to belong
they want to improve their English their
skill set they really feel safe and
happy here and really want to contribute
but what do we tell them as immigration
practitioners or as a country for now we
still need to go through a lot to feel
really like we belong that this is ours
this family will enjoy the simple joys
of being together being safe building
towards something new and we have now
many friends here it's so valuable many
people are helping us perhaps not
something they chose but something they
Embrace we really want to thank every
single person that aided Us in this
journey
thank you everybody for all your support
for your friendship we do have hope
well it's not Ukraine anymore but it is
home now we wish them the best all right
it's not yet summer here in the U.S but
in Antarctica Believe It or Not summer
has just ended and the researchers from
San Jose who spent the season there well
they were living next to some very
interesting Neighbors
CBS Bay area's Brian Hackney brought
back this report
but Hamilton has picked up some snow the
camera started to snow here where we are
in 17 is just tonight it was a real
nightmare trying to get back down
because the ice freezes unusual
meteorological conditions for us we
don't usually see in the forecast snow
in the Santa Cruz
[Laughter]
a closure to study emperor penguins
they're great neighbors they're really
curious birds and kind of wondering what
kind of weird penguin you are
it's my first time on the ice stepping
off the helicopter I almost cried
because I was so happy
this year our goal is to instrument 32
Birds
we're hoping to learn where they're
going how deep they're diving how hard
they have to work to get their food it
involves a lot of logistics so we get up
in the morning pack up our research gear
and we head out
and then just catching penguins
once we find the penguin that we want to
capture we surround it the bird doesn't
really know what to do kind of stand
still and we're able to get within three
or four feet of it and then we have
these long hooks kind of like a
shepherd's crook that we just
um can hook around the bird and pull it
towards us and then basically give the
bird a big hug
so we spend a lot of time in the
beginning deploying tags getting a
flipper measurement getting a blood
sample if possible and if they've got a
transmitter on them so we have an
antenna and we can scan and when it goes
we know we have a penguin
we capture these devices from the backs
of these penguins we download the data
and it allows us to do really
interesting things such as know where
the Penguins go while they're at Sea
whether it was standing if it was
swimming we're actually able to count
how many strokes The Penguin took on its
Journey it's pretty pretty incredible
the work is very
of information we didn't know it before
certainly as a polar species they're
going to be some of the first that will
be affected by climate change
they show up at the breeding season and
the ice isn't there so they have nowhere
to breathe so that probably is going to
be happening more and more frequently
where we're going to be losing chicks
just due to ice going away
some of the best things you can do is
just reduce your carbon footprint and
just caring about biodiversity is
important and protecting that
biodiversity
and Penguins especially these penguins
are Sentinels of change they're sort of
the canaries in the coal mine
all right coming up meet a five-year-old
with cerebral palsy who's learning how
to navigate life from a role model who
has the very same muscular disorder
I hope Colby just finds her real voice
she's capable of doing anything I just
hope that it's part of her and that
she's proud of it because if I could go
back to that five-year-old girl I would
doubt
I could go back to my five-year-old self
I would tell her
[Music]
a five-year-old with cerebral palsy
found an important friend and role model
in a fitness coach who also has that
very same muscular disorder the two live
in different parts of the country but
CBS News was there when they finally got
together and met in person for the very
first time here's Elaine quijano
now I can pour some orange juice in it
okay
like other five-year-olds Colby gerbero
spends a lot of time in a world of
Make-Believe here you go thank you so
much but her reality has differed since
birth Colby was born 17 weeks premature
at one pound two ounces she's faced a
host of health challenges since
including the muscular disorder cerebral
palsy or CP CP is where you have like CP
and and you use like a locker or cane
and wheelchair these days Colby is
realizing that others sometimes see her
differently she said Mommy I don't like
when people stare at me Mommy I don't
like it I want them to stop I want Colby
to know that she can pick up the phone
and call me for whatever reason Steph
roach was also born with CP she and
Colby's mom Amanda met through social
media where roach a former CrossFit
trainer and book author posts about her
life and defying expectations when I saw
Colby and then I saw the way that Amanda
was guiding Colby through life it was
just like we were meant to to be friends
until now it's been a long distance
friendship the derberos in New Jersey
and roach in Arizona ready come on out
but one January morning who is it
they had their first meeting guess what
you came here I guess what I got I got
they were immediately comfortable with
each other can I pick you up
I can't believe like you're here
I love you as Colby realizes that people
are starting to look at her and see her
maybe a little bit differently so we've
had some big conversations about how
that might make her feel and yeah I I
know all about how I feel about it is it
okay to tell somebody that you don't
like it yeah we have to be nice about it
yeah but you can still tell somebody
that I don't really like how you stare
at me like that if you have questions I
can answer them for you right yeah if
people have questions they can ask you
after Colby went to play roach
remembered her own childhood I wanted to
be as quote normal as possible but it
really wasn't until I turned probably 20
22 where I really started to own who I
was with self-acceptance came new
chapters a growing circle of friends
success in Fitness competitions and Love
Is it true you met Tyler on Tinder it is
very true and I remember telling him you
know hope this doesn't bother you but I
have CP and he said well I'm pigeon toed
so I hope that doesn't bother you just
months into their relationship her life
changed again during a doctor's visit in
2016. these lumps were all throughout my
body and a couple weeks later I was
diagnosed with Hodgkin's lymphoma stage
3B it took 12 rounds of chemotherapy
before doctors said her scans were clear
Steph and Ty have since married and
faced the out outside world together
we've been in a grocery store and a man
has literally come up to him and shaken
his hand and said like so good of you to
be with her and like why isn't he lucky
to also be with me she can't stand but
she's a wheelchair for me what would
your hope for Colby be gosh I mean so
many things you know as a mom you just
have all the Hope in the world you know
I used to think that because she had CP
she would be an artist because she
couldn't be an athlete and now I know
that the world is her oyster My Hope Is
that she's exactly who she wants to be
and stuff I hope Colby just finds her
real voice she's capable of doing
anything I just hope that it's part of
her and that she's proud of it because
if I could go back to that five-year-old
girl I would doubt
if if I could go back to my
five-year-old self I would tell her to
be proud of herself
at the end of the day it's all about
that human connection it's a beautiful
story Elaine thank you very much that is
our show I'm confident it brightened
your day lifted you up if for some
reason it didn't the reruns they do
remain free meantime I'm gonna go find
some good news
thank you